Je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel
[Musique]
avant [
Musique] [
Musique]
Ouais, les gens sont assez alarmés quand ils
voient de l'
écume de mer, mais l'écume de mer est en grande partie une protéine
qui provient de la dégradation de la
matière organique dans les océans et qui
serait en grande partie des
algues planctoniques  un peu de champignon
un peu de bactérie et au fur et à mesure qu'il se
dégrade,
il forme quelque chose qui ressemble un peu
aux tensioactifs ou aux
agents moussants que nous verrions et donc
dans l'ensemble,
ces événements d'écume de mer naturels
ne sont pas
dommageables et font partie d'un  cycle naturel
[Musique]
[Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
Eh bien, ce que nous avons ici est un autre
événement météorologique extrême
qui se produit à la suite du changement climatique et auquel
notre communauté fait face, il s'agit
du quatrième ou cinquième
événement majeur  au cours des deux dernières années
en ce moment autour de byron, nous avons eu des
houles massives par temps violent, nous regardons notre plage
[Musique]
disparaître
vous